I just got a lot to say to this so I was
just on this panel okay
I was just on this panel and I'm in
Miami I'm doing a podcast in Miami
and I was on with this girl okay and
they asked you what would you expect
from your man a month for like
maintenance
and your girl pearl
and I'm I'm having a hard time thinking
about it because
I'm like I mean I get my nails done here
and there
but even that's like every other month
Maybe
I don't really do much with my hair I
just brush it I wear like a little
makeup but not a lot so I was just
thinking like
what would that cost me and someone on
the panel said two thousand dollars
a month
and they were saying that was on the low
end that was one of the lowest answers
what the hell are you [ __ ] spending
two thousand dollars a month on you
could not maybe maybe I'm a tomboy maybe
I'm mid maybe whatever but for two
thousand dollars a month I will be mid
and I will be happily mid because you
will not catch me they got these last
lifts
they got they're like talking about they
get lash lifts hair extensions
um spray tan it's like all this [ __ ] I'm
like just go out looking like yourself
you're gonna put all that [ __ ] on you're
not gonna look like you the men don't
want this they don't want to go to bed
next to a girl and wake up and she looks
like a different person two grand a
month
what maybe maybe I'm just ugly I don't
know but I just I could not wrap my head
and that was the low end the low end
ladies okay
but please stop telling your man that
you need this money to survive I'm sorry
I've lived my life most of my life I did
not get my nails done most of my life I
wore very little to no makeup and I've
been just fine honestly some would argue
I've monetized my looks
and I don't wear makeup and I don't put
all that [ __ ] on
someone are you some would say maybe
being mid helps me I don't know you guys
you guys put
you guys argue about my looks all the
time in the comments I don't need that
here my point is two grand okay let's
just do the math on this two thousand
dollars
twenty four thousand dollars a year
that's a salary that you're just
spending on yourself and this is what I
mean when I say modern women are selfish
24 Grand a year
that's your kids college funds what are
y'all gonna do
when you have actual children you can't
afford that stuff anymore
because I'm sorry once you have kids
uh two grand a month I'm freaking
Nails clothes hair shoes and maybe y'all
should be saving for the for when you
actually have kids
I just want to know where are they
getting this money from the average
woman makes like 35 000 a year
sorry guys 35 Grand
look it so this is just my message to
the ladies I don't really care spend
your money how you want to spend your
money but don't tell me you need a man
that makes six figures when you spend 2K
a month on freaking stuff you don't need
because got ladies you don't need to get
your teeth whitened you don't need to
get the fake lash extensions you don't
need the eyebrow lifts you don't need
the botox you don't need the fake hair
you don't need any of that [ __ ]
so why are you having the men
pay for [ __ ] that you don't even need
that's like me
saying I demand the men
pay for or the men coming to me
and telling me to pay for their shoe
collection
and they'll be like oh well you like my
shoe collection
I didn't ask you to wear the shoe
collection and look if you men if you
want to pay that that's fine and maybe
they said something on the panel they're
like well the more attractive the girl
the more expensive she'll be so maybe
I'm just cheap I don't know but you
won't catch me dead spending two grand a
month on freaking clothes hair
guys clothes go in and out of style
every single year
like I'm sorry get a couple Timeless
pieces I've improved I know my sounds
bad I've improved it a lot this year but
I swear to Jesus I am my goal with these
clothes is to never I hate shopping
and you some of you all need to get
Hobbies because the other thing is how
much time
the time it takes I get annoyed getting
my nails done
this is something I've implemented this
year I get annoyed
because I might have to sit there for
two hours like this annoys me
two grand
anyways
like the video on your way out y'all are
crazy goodbye